disney fans around the world swear
movies like milan and moana are the
studio's best
but its newest edition raya and the last
dragon is fighting for that top spot
we've found major similarities between
our newest warrior princess raya
and mulan and moana's stories that we'll
never be able to unsee
which got us thinking will this make her
the best of both worlds
or just a repeat let's find out
wait wait wait wait you touched this gem
piece and it gave you powers
mulan and raya both wield a weapon that
looks a little
too similar to be a coincidence the
sword we see
raya used to fight is almost identical
to the sword mulan is given by the
emperor after saving china
you fight good
okay we might just be acting a bit
dramatic but you can't deny the
similarities
just look at the shape of the blade and
the design of the guard
whether it was intentional or not one
thing's for sure
these two warriors are resourceful with
any weapons they get their hands on
don't die if you weren't obsessed with
eddie murphy's version of mushu as a kid
did you even watch milan the hilarious
dragon that helped mulan on her
adventures until the very end
who did a good job come on we did a good
job
well people couldn't help but notice
that raya also has a dragon companion
who's
also voiced by a comedian aquafina
brought raya's sidekick sisu to life
and we have to admit the energy she
brings to the screen is
basically the female version of eddie
murphy we can definitely see how people
might think that these characters are
one and the same
i just changed dragons can do that wait
there are more similarities when it
comes to raya's sidekicks
so we know moana starts off her journey
past the horizon alone
but then realizes she has to work with
her stowaway friend heihei
maui and even gets help from the ocean
raya's journey is
eerily similar she starts off alone but
soon puts together a whole team of
misfits
it gets even more identical raya's
companion tuktuk
is voiced by the same actor who brought
moana's heihei to life
alan tudyk their two-syllable names are
even similar
i went to julia if there's one thing
that's hot at disney and disney studios
right now
it's female independence long gone are
the times where princesses depend on
their prince to help save the day
arguably mulan was the first example of
this new vision
sure she fell in love with lee shang but
he wasn't the one who saved chyna was
he we also saw it in moana she actually
had no love interest whatsoever
you are not my hero but that didn't make
the movie any less entertaining
in fact you can probably say it made it
more unique well
raya followed right in their footsteps
she'll stop at nothing to reunite
kumandra
even if that means finding the last
dragon all by herself
if they did take inspiration from mulan
and moana in this department
we're not gonna complain about them
giving princesses more agency in 2021
we should be celebrating hello see sue
we need you the whole premise of moana
is her becoming the fearless leader she
wants to be for her people
she sets out on her journey to reunite
the goddess te fiti with the stone heart
in order to save montenui and its people
[Music]
raya has the exact same goal find the
last dragon and order will be restored
amongst her people if we look even
further into this
it's almost like they're searching for
their culture's identity
by correcting the mistakes of their
ancestors
our world's broken we all know how
important the blossoms were in mulan
they're in her hair piece under the tree
where she has a heart to heart with her
father
and she's even compared to the flower
not to mention the flower hairpiece is
what she leaves her father before
running off
for raya flowers are also very symbolic
they're also above where she talks with
her father and pop up in a bunch of
other places across the film
there's no doubt that mulan and raya
both have strong bonds with their
fathers
while their relationships may be
different in nature they're still both
huge
factors in both films but what we were
more taken aback by
was how similar the imagery between
mulan and her father was to raya and her
father
i'm ready to serve the emperor in a
different
way moana's relationship with her dad
matches raya and her fathers as well
the father figure in both movies is the
reason why they set
out on their journey sure moana does it
despite her father's wishes
and raya does it because of her father's
influence
but they're both in very similar
situations not to mention they're both
inheriting broken kingdoms from their
dads
this is how we help our people dad
raya and the last dragon might take
place in the fantasy world of kumandra
but that doesn't mean that it isn't
based on a real life location
raya's character and land take on a huge
representation of southeast asian
culture
and disney wanted to make sure that they
got all the details right
that's why their creative team spent
weeks traveling to places like cambodia
lao thailand vietnam
singapore indonesia and the philippines
you're getting a little too big for this
bud
their writers even worked alongside the
southeast asia story trust
and had to get all their art and designs
approved by the cultural workers in
indonesia guess what the brains behind
moana had almost an identical research
process
they traveled to polynesia and worked
with the oceanic trust that was made up
of anthropologists and cultural
professionals and traveled to islands
like samoa and fiji
everything right down to the rock's
groundbreaking your welcome performance
was thought out by this group
safe to say there's a reason why disney
is one of the most popular production
companies
martial arts and the importance it has
on chinese culture is a huge part of
mulan's story
the chinese warrior she is based on hua
mulan was said to be an expert at
martial arts after all
and in the live-action version that was
released by disney they made sure to
work with professionals so they could
have
accurate choreography well for raya
martial arts is just as important
my sword here says we're not she was
trained all her life
in order to defend the dragon gem a
martial arts consultant that worked on
raya and the last dragon
says that if you pay close enough
attention you can catch a bunch of
different
southeast asian martial arts practices
could raya be taking over as the world's
most popular warrior princess
the 1998 mulan did get a lot of
criticism for not being respectful of
chinese culture
so we can totally see raya getting bonus
points for being more aware of what
they're showing on the screen
seriously speaking of ancestors mulan
moana and raya
are all based on real-life cultural
mythology mulan was of course
loosely based on the myth of the chinese
warrior hua mulan
moana isn't included in any polynesian
tales
but the demigod maui is he's been part
of their folklore for thousands of years
and for raya her tale isn't based on one
specific southeast asian story
but more of a combination from multiple
different countries mythology
the theme of mythology even comes into
play in the actual film
both moana and raya are basing their
journeys on the land's folk tales and
history
i never should have put so much on your
shoulders
we talked a little bit about how moana
and raya's movies had basically the
exact same research strategy
and well it probably has to do with the
fact that moana and raya and the last
dragon
have the exact same producers even just
by taking a glimpse at the trailer for
raya and the last dragon
you can see similarities in the
animation and coloring
to do in the film is nothing less than
save the world
what do you think is raya too similar to
mulan and moana
or is it just the right amount we're
thinking that these shared qualities
might help her pave her own way
straight to the top of the disney
princess chain looks like it could be
another one for the disney history books
right
either way it's still pretty amazing
that disney is giving us all new
princess warriors
let us know if you noticed even more
similarities between
raya and any other animated faves